now let's take a look at one of the
hardest things to deal with with working
with the app cache the fact that you
have to remember to update the
application cache let's say we change
something in our file let's add a title
now let's save this and go back and try
to reload again now you'll notice that
even though i saved the index.html file
nothing happened to the cash it's
because the only thing that was checked
was the cache file the manifest and we
didn't touch the manifest at all so
let's go back and do that now so in the
manifest we need to do some actual
change to the file we can't just touch
it with a command-line utility touch
that actually won't trigger a reload so
let's just add a version number hit save
and now let's go back and reload again
this time you'll see again we've
downloaded the cash but remember what
we're seeing here what the user is seen
here is not actually the new content it
loaded it from the cache and then
updated the cash not in real time that
way the user gets the content
immediately while they still get updated
content now we can listen for the event
on cash updated and the cash update
event will tell us that the user really
needs to pick a good time to reload we
could surface that by popping a dialog
box that says hey this application is
updated do you want to reload now but
that can also be postponed and you can
just presume that the user will get a
new version when they hit refresh again
if I hit refresh one more time now it's
pulling it from the cash again and I
have the updated content over here